what's up y'all Friday time for our
little daily sidetrack yeah we just got
done doing a movie reviews yeah we did
we just recorded the matinee show so
that'll go up on Sunday unless you're a
patron in which case you will be able to
see it on Saturday morning yeah so
hopefully you guys are enjoying I just
put up the review of Black Rain hey
Ridley Scott movie so I put that up
earlier today so go check that out if
you haven't already I just noticed like
in the camera I have this little jacket
over my shirt that looks like it's this
black move on it it's a Black Moon
actually Sophie sent me this shirt it
says you can't you guys can't see it but
it says the 13th hour on the bottom
which is you know cuz 13 o'clock so
let's see today
we went to Walgreens now I've been a
Walgreens in like a really long time I
had to go to get some feminine hygiene
products so yeah so I had to go there
you know what they've done well it was
pretty well stocked like I even got some
soup and [ __ ] like that while I was
there because apparently no one's buying
soup there except like hey they have a
soup they also had those damned NT more
MRE things those Toni Betty Ocella and
to him for six bucks or to him for 6
bucks which yeah was it - is it for 6 no
I think it was three four weeks dollars
so they were two dollars each yeah which
actually isn't bad it's not bad so and
you know I mean they had about well they
only had about eight of them there well
yeah it's not their main I mean if you
are going there people aren't going
there because they don't know that they
have them there but you could go clean
that [ __ ] out if you wanted them yes did
he warp I bought a bunch of super
because they had them like two for three
dollars yeah chunky soup the big fans
I got protein soup I got those lemony
likes those lemon think bar bars I like
those are good I have I bought other
flavors of those think protein bars it's
like some of them are better than others
yeah like anyone with peanut butter in
it is usually good the lemon ones are
usually good some of the other ones like
I love mint but whenever I get nutrition
bars they always taste really drunk
they're dry yeah I think I don't even
know it's it they're like really weirdly
heavy and it's like doesn't taste
exactly like mint it's a little
off-putting to think lemon bars and to
think strawberry ones
or strawberry yeah yeah it was buried
with coconut or some strawberry cuz I
think I got a coconut one of them
they're they're good it's gonna lemon
one actually tastes like a dessert yeah
and it's you know we do they both do and
it doesn't really have that much sugar
in it it's not really really low sugar
yeah in there and you know it's there I
think they're like 100-something
calories and it's like 20 grams of
proteins that's kind of like having a
protein shake
yeah some like well some of the ones cuz
we have some too that you got it Sam's
or whatever that we have peanut butter
ones and mint ones those mint ones are
pretty good I don't know good body will
survive with food too
those are 260 calories but that I use
them as like a meal replacement yeah
like you know what I mean if I'm not
gonna be eating breakfast or I'm not
gonna be eating lunch I've been
something really good in an MRE yeah
this shelf-stable they're light you
could put them in a pack you know I mean
you could you can put them in a rucksack
and you could let you could kinda kind
of like equivalent to a chicken breast
nationally so you know as long as you
get ones that don't have a shit's on a
sugar and yeah so I like to think bars
yeah and then there's some other ones
that I got from Sam's got a big little
thing they were really good but people
forget about those you know you know
they'll get all these MREs no survival
[ __ ] and can of stuff they forget all
about all that [ __ ] bodybuilding
nutritional supplement stuff is like
sustenance yeah well that whey protein
you could almost live off that well like
I said the ones that we got from Sam's
that that are mint once they're mint
ones and peanut butter ones it's two
different flavors in one box and I don't
remember what the brand was it's built
or something or whatever yeah builders
and those are and those are - those are
20 grams of protein I think that's very
very low sugar I think it's like less
than 5 grams of sugar and they're 260
calories it tastes good like in one bar
and they're both of both the flavors are
actually really good that doesn't Sam's
I think for a $20 from big [ __ ] box
oh yeah we still have a chef I mean it's
like half and half peanut butter and
chocolate and mint and mint and
chocolate yeah but yeah some of them are
pretty good like you know what I mean
it's a weak trilling - they are and like
yeah once I've eaten that I'm like yeah
Dorney be there they're heavy yeah
they're very dense but yeah so we're at
Walgreens and like I said they had soup
so I picked up a bunch of soup
I think the OL
they were out of was it looked like the
paper aisle was kind of cleared out you
know there was no toilet paper no
anything like that
but other than that it looked like
everything was pretty well stocked you
know what they were certain to do is
that um you know because everybody's
saying you know stay six feet apart from
the the sidewalk outside they drew big
chalk squares six feet apart and they
put tape on the floor inside six feet so
everyone could stay sick I'm like well
yes in the checkouts area no and her and
I were occupying the same space she's
looking to meet you know that like get
your germy ass off her I'm like she's
like she's like you guys together and
said yeah it's like otherwise back off
yeah cuz you're supposed to stay like
what yeah and you know what I mean I'm
kind of hoping that they cuz we use one
of those little hand baskets and they
didn't have any wipes or anything so I'm
really kind of hoping I mean we washed
the this [ __ ] out of our hands when we
got home and everything good I said I
hope they're hosing those down with us
yeah but you know I just wanted to
mention that some of that kind of hard
to find canned goods and survival
oriented stuff like the den team or
stuff and protein bars and [ __ ] whey
protein and [ __ ] like that
health food stuff walgreens got people
forgetting about that they're getting
everything from the damn supermarket
yeah and I mean I just had we weren't
even gonna play I wasn't gonna get any
food you know a lot of [ __ ] was half off
did you notice yeah I did like I said
the super super cheap that's why I got
like I got like four or five minutes
monster drinks and energy drinks are all
half off yeah I got a I got a coffee
drink yeah there's good deals going on
right now
yeah it looked like it was like
untouched yeah I've got a pair of them
damn gargoyle [ __ ] shooting glasses
from [ __ ] terminator one I got him
for $35 delivered and like you said 95
we're gonna go to the store they're
gonna be a hundred yeah retail that's it
brick-and-mortar retail alright so we
had a request to talk about tattoos you
to show and tell you just have one you
just said no I got three different ones
that become became that became one it
over time they're just military tattoos
I'm gonna show ya the Eagle and infantry
thing a [ __ ] 101st airborne crest and
a [ __ ] recon tab above that I'll show
my ones yeah I just have to uh well
technically I have three because one's a
cover-up I got ready ass [ __ ]
barracks tattoos this one here is
obviously uh Anubis yeah I got this one
many years ago I got this one just
because I'm super into Egyptian
mythology and always have been and I
always liked that iconography there it's
that's really the only reason it's you
know it's it's a little bit faded
because I've had it for so long now this
other tattoo here this originally
originally I had um a little like a
tribal looking like a tiny little barn
owl up here and it was just all black I
got that when I was really young I think
I was only like 19 or 20 when I got it
and um all the lines had kind of faded
together and stuff it was still cold but
it's like you couldn't really tell what
it was anymore it's just art of look
blah be the devil did that tattoo yes so
we can read we have this friend named
Jacob yeah he's in France right now it
[ __ ] he's he's running the show he's
kind of a small celebrities been on TV a
lot in central South America yeah he's
kind of like he's originally were salami
yeah he's Colombian he was a Colombian
Army sniper yeah and his his cool dude
and he's yeah he's super skinny he looks
like the devil you see him now he's got
[ __ ] he puts on a show where he wears
big old [ __ ] devil [ __ ] platforms
and wings and [ __ ] horns coming out
of his head and and he was a tattoo
artist once he got out of the army and
his brother his older brother was a
[ __ ] Colombian army officer I've got
two kids the [ __ ] war crimes but he
got out of it his brother his brother
commanded a unit a [ __ ] machine gun
to bunch of [ __ ] rebels yeah what
they were prisoners though but it was it
was my understanding based honest to
what I remember the story you know it
was kind of understandable they couldn't
take him with them because they had to
they were basically retreating and they
could
let him go or this is what a retreat
they just want to rejoined the enemy
they were terrorists so they [ __ ]
machine condom but yeah we we met Jacob
he lived here for a short time he was
married to a friend of ours for a brief
time period maybe like a year or two and
we so we would kind of like hang out at
the clubs with them and whatnot and he
did some performances here as well like
I said it's what is what is his stage
name what is the stage amber man I can't
but I can't remember it either he did a
lot of Central American and South
American talk show he looks [ __ ]
great yeah he's been on TV and stuff
like that done he married a friend of
ours temporarily that didn't last but
yeah so he actually um I had been you
can assert a photograph of it yeah yeah
I'll find one I have lots of pictures
yeah but um yeah so he was a tattoo
artist also and I had been thinking
about doing a cover up on this little
bitty al just cuz it was starting to
look so crappy because it was so old it
was the first one I got and basically I
just let him do I said well I just want
something sort of owl base but I was
like I had seen like a lot of his
artwork in his portfolio yeah he was a
baby he was I guess you could say he was
a private tattooer he did this in our
house yeah which they not supposed to do
in this state but he's in another
country so [ __ ] it yeah he's in France
and he's not couple it's not like they
can do anything they can't doing that
and he did that in one setting ten hours
ten hours i sat there for ten hours yeah
because I didn't want him to have to
like come back yeah so so he just stayed
they they did the money yeah they just
stayed over to our house and it's like
we just kind of set up in our in the
front of the bathroom yeah and it's like
Tommy's always asleep his wife fell
asleep
yeah healed up pretty good yeah there's
a couple parts for some because some of
the colour fell out of it if he was here
to touch that up for you but yes she is
good enough yeah but I just I basically
just let him run wild I said just take
something that's sort of like a soup so
he did this kind of OWL goddess kind of
theme cuz like I said I really liked his
artwork so I said you can do whatever
you want on early care just cover-up is
whatever his wife's name is Aurora
we have videos of her he's he stuck a
couple [ __ ] hooks they were back yeah
suspended her from the ceiling in this
club that we were at it's like a pretty
cool yeah that was a great show actually
yeah they were just two years ago just I
was at the grotto that's not there
anymore
put some big-ass [ __ ] huge fish hooks
through her and yet she's just she's
swinging around and you know they were
just that was like some [ __ ] that you
did to [ __ ] joy and like that Apache
Tribe was nothing yeah but yeah they had
a couple shows like that so I think
Jacob still doing good I still see him
he's on my jam talked to him a couple
days yeah he's still on my Instagram so
he's in France he said he's making a
bunch of money and putting on shows and
that everybody loved his act and it went
his act didn't work here in the United
States but it worked it worked in in
Europe Harry he had too much competition
yeah I got Disney here and I like that
people are so jaded they don't give a
[ __ ] about that
yeah and they're sending to France where
he'd be a super oddity and I mean he can
he can book shows yeah but he's a super
cool dude he's a really nice guy even
though like you know I think most most
normal people which I do not count
myself among would probably see him and
think he was like terrifying looking and
stuff like that but he is actually like
a sweet dude which a lot of those people
are he's ski guy so the only the only
other question we got and I kind of
answered it but I wasn't entirely sure
because you weren't here to ask somebody
asked about your Mazinger figures so
which one they they just said well those
mazinger's are they figures or are they
kits like did you build them oh one of
them is a model okay see that's what I
thought
yeah and that's that's not a Mazinger
that's it that's a getter yeah that's a
model the one in the back was a was one
that it was just a vinyl figure and I
painted it yeah that's a really good
paint job on it one of the backs is you
the to the front of band eyes and that's
those are diecast metal basically action
figures they're fully articulated the
the the grand eyes are inside the UFO
and
zimas Inger in the back there and the
[ __ ] Duke fleet Reich and the [ __ ]
TF oh those are HL pros and I'm friends
with the with the guy who owns HL Perot
yeah actually I helped conceive some HL
pros newer products we were talking
about him online and stuff for a long
long time if you look up King gory King
we talked King gory into [ __ ]
existence which is a damn cybernetic
gorilla King gorilla King Kong but it's
a that was that was a japanese ripoff
yeah but he owns a japanese a french guy
who lives in japan married a Japanese
woman is his kids are Japanese he's
lived there forever and it's just a guy
that I was friends with people in the
comic but kind of [ __ ] it had to do
with [ __ ] gods and monsters and the
guys on gods and monsters and PBM which
is a company that imports stuff trying
to get into compas is back when comic
book shops kind of made money and that's
how I fell in with the guys that or at
least one of the guys that makes these
things yeah cuz you kind of got a lot
you were kind of instrumental in when or
not gods and monsters before that was
Acme Acme and you were they were just
starting to import like all of these
jackets like all the knobs and stuff and
you were kind of like helping them out
because she knew about it up there
trying to get that up there's a bunch
more of them yeah there you go alright
and those are mostly band eyes in HL
broad I can he's got [ __ ] I got a bunch
of [ __ ] vinyl action figures of
[ __ ] great mazinger Mazinger Z
[ __ ] grand Iser that went up to that
big one in the back that's a model that
I've built a vinyl model that's a
[ __ ] custom black getter that I made
out of vinyl and [ __ ] a bunch of
other stuff I made that years of years
back now but that's pretty cool other
the fact that it's a vinyl and the paint
that I used it all worked out fine but
that vinyl is releasing gas and all that
paint is sticky as [ __ ] if you grab it
you get fingerprints in it and then a
couple days later the fingerprint
vanishes it all just evens back out but
you don't want to touch it
made a mistake which is why it's up
there mistake with with that one but it
looks good yeah yeah so you can see he
has like a humongous yeah collection
yeah I've kind of fell behind there's
some newer ones that had one yeah
because you haven't bought a need for
head body while yeah cuz he used to get
like the new one every time that it came
yeah yeah HL Pro woods and but the bad
guy wants the new the new seller should
go can line I kind of like it because
it's a copy of an HL Pro HL Pro scopes
we're doing so good the band I started
to to copy there yeah which HL pros a
tiny little company it's like two or
three guys working you know in a studio
and they're having it made over in China
and they bring them in Ben does a huge
corporation and that's kind of Honor
when well yeah operation starts copying
you well because HL Pro like you said
it's this small and they do it because
they love it yeah and they put a lot of
work into their sculpts and with the
toys and everything I mean when they
release one it's like top of the line
yeah and when they make these things
they don't really make any money off
them yeah the way I don't see where the
money's made is little vinyl things
keychains [ __ ] mugs all the other
merch yeah [ __ ] you could sell for
[ __ ] 5 or 6 bucks that's what really
makes all the money
yeah those those hundred and thirty
dollar figures you know yeah I'm gonna
sell it made out of damn metal and stuff
because a lot of this stuff's metal for
you people don't know some of buy half
of it is but the metal ones are
expensive and there's just no profit in
them yeah you know making them because
there are fans and yeah it's a show it's
a showboat thing yeah it gives your
brand credibility that you can make
diecast articulated robots yeah but
that's not where the profit the profits
in vinyl making mass-producing these
little vinyl $30 vinyl figures that's
where the [ __ ] profit is well yeah
obviously because more people buy that
right now but yeah so if anybody wanted
to know about all the robots yeah we've
got a massive collection yeah I don't
really have much of a collection of
anything I have some like MSD figures
but that's Frankenstein's and witches
and I got frankincense which they got
all like Holly you gotta clean your
connect collect
some of that stuff is not high value
really when we should be getting you
some really cool which though I'm not
worried about high value yeah I just
have stuff because I like it yeah you
know what I mean guys know how I am
I like badass [ __ ] look how much that
guy okay yeah alright I'll give that in
a couple months you know yeah well you
know I'm like that
I'm just kind of like I don't know I
feel like I don't really have a lot of
money to spend on stuff like that so
it's like I haven't really about
anything like that and if I do have
extra money I usually buy like a mess I
like to collect [ __ ] you know the man
yeah and I like to collect [ __ ] that's
it's kind of expensive and kind of rare
and when you go to sell it you know I
mean you could at least get your money
back yeah some of this stuff you could
actually kind of make money on it if it
if it goes real rare you know
yeah and really what goes most what
really goes rare is the [ __ ] that was
unpopular you know so yeah because
nobody bother everywhere they bought it
and then it end up kind of getting
thrown away and then 15 20 years later a
collector goes I need the you know I
need the Duke fleed trike you know where
are they you know there aren't any
around anymore
you know so then it's $100 it's $100
figure that's yeah well some people
absolutely do pay hundreds and hundreds
of dollars yeah
those big those big here the Jumbo's
those big Jumbo's up there I've got to
get a chest piece for that one but I
kind of rebuilt those and you know new
stickers and [ __ ] like that those used
to be able to get them for a hundred
bucks like a couple years back on eBay
now good ones about 400 yeah and that's
that's the American cops
that's the American copies of the
they're not really copies but the
American licensed versions through
Mattel I also had some pokey ones which
were the original Japanese ones those
things can go for like depending on what
character is four or five thousand
dollars well because a lot of those were
built they were for kids and they're
cheap and then they were thrown away got
thrown out or they got broken or
whatever because kids played with them
and that's why I like a lot of
types of toys like people are paying a
lot of money for that [ __ ] now because
not a lot of people captain but yeah
they didn't think they were gonna livin
out in California kid my mom bought me
one of them it was uh what was the name
of it a combate ler combate lurvy or
combate or five I'm not sure what he was
called or you know I just said combated
and then a V but the Japanese probably
meant combative v yeah that's probably
what it was I had one of those and I
didn't know it but there were only 20 of
them in the United States they came
through a place called Pinocchio's toy
shop which is a Japanese toy shop out in
California to serve the Japanese
community that lived there yeah my mom
bought me one of those they were about a
hundred bucks back in the 70s yikes yeah
six about that
moved to Brazil took it with me I threw
it out in a dumpster it's worth about
six thousand yeah if I kept the Box
twice [ __ ] like that happens you kind of
understand why some people become
hoarders yeah yeah they had a box you
just keep everything they had the boxes
pride about 6,000 yeah without the box
probably more like 400 my food away yeah
last time I saw it was sitting in a damn
dumpster well girls appeared once girls
start coming into the game you know
you're 14 15 years old [ __ ] toy start
getting donut which like I said and
that's quite so many of them yeah
alright so why you want to wrap up the
Friday sidetrack alright so yeah we're
good we're gonna make pizza
hey he's making pizza he made dough the
other day and there's a major in sauce
got that stone heating up in there yeah
525 degrees yeah we're gonna have some
pizza any minute
so uh be safe and healthy you guys and
we'll talk to you again tomorrow